[Applause]
[Music]
welcome everybody to the uh special
halloween edition
of the show
today we are in a extremely haunted
location and taking it very seriously
we're here with linda the ghost hunter
are you a ghost hunter i am a ghost
hunter you want to tell me about
yourself a little bit yeah so i've been
a ghost hunter for 15 years what i try
and expose people to like yourselves is
the fact that there is spirits and we're
able to communicate with them and
they're not all bad not all bad not all
bad some are bad some are bad
i've had some very bad experiences i've
been thrown
brilliantly yeah yeah i get broke my
nose oh my goodness that was a bad one
yeah the background on this location
here yeah seems like there could be some
evil spirits lurking based on the
history of this location of course i
mean there's been a lot of deaths here
and not everybody that dies is great not
everybody that dies is good and some
were never on this earth in the first
place
those are the ones we really worry about
guys those are the ones that demons the
demons where you have they have never
walked this earth i very often when i
say that's why does that make you feel
scared i'm like scared shitless who
here's is actually like a little spooked
right now we got olivia lina av are you
spooked right now that got me scared
well i am here to protect you too if you
notice i'm wearing a lot of jewelry and
these right here are the mystic eye the
protection of the evil eye and i also
will be surrounding us with the white
light to make sure that we are
surrounded by love will this protect me
against anything do you know
are they like jews or no where we are
there is a a jewish history here that
i'm going to tell you about originally
in the early 1900s this was an indian
burial ground okay so this was a
cemetery that we're actually standing on
and we're going to go take a look at
this cemetery it later became a jewish
cemetery cut to 10 years later they
decide no no no no we don't want the
cemetery here this is a great part of
town we're going to need this space
we're going to move all the bodies okay
here's where the story gets a little
weird there's no proof that these bodies
were actually moved so there's a very
good chance that people are still buried
underneath a paved area that we're going
to go to what's the chance of recovering
a body tonight
um no floaters i don't think we had
enough rain today yeah but you know on a
rainier day you never know after they
decide hey okay we're gonna we're gonna
move this there was a smallpox epidemic
so you decided hey let's make this a
kind of a hospital but the hospital was
isolation and a lot of them did not make
it they called it the wagon of death so
we've got the native americans yes the
jews
the smallpox yeah so can you show us a
little of the
equipment we'll be using this evening
the equipment i brought tonight is all
scientifically proven to work with
paranormal activity that's an emf
detector that'll tell us if we have any
fluctuation in emf around us this gadget
right here is called the k2 but if i
were to ask a question like is someone
here with us right now and it would move
then you know we're on to some these are
the dowsing rods now this one is not for
the faint of heart because this is the
hands-on one this is when you're
actually holding them like this
and you say if someone's here with me
can you please cross the rods you will
physically feel these moves those if
you're interested in zach's life energy
across the streams
[ __ ] moving it
this the obvious five is pretty much the
creme de la creme stars okay that
actually just spoke okay
older stars star david why why is it
talking so much it it
ran
okay obviously somebody's been dying to
speak with us now tell me how's this is
just reading okay so what this does
this is a fantastic device it has one
million words it uses emf as i spoke
earlier but it actually takes the energy
with these two antennas and it
translates it towards david
does it really it says david it really
does starve david
yeah this is a thermal imaging camera so
we're not equipped to vanquish spirits
this evening well no but if we do have a
problem i can bring someone in what
about like
finishing their business
unfinished business like parking ticket
or something well a lot of that that's
very common for ghost instagram for
parking tickets i'm glad you brought
that up that's i think that's the number
one reason that ghosts come back in my
research i really have found there's
there's really three types of ghosts
there's the ones that have died suddenly
they got hit by a car they have no clue
they're dead they're just wandering
around fifth or the fifth
four six cents yeah the success yeah
yeah i see dead people yeah he didn't
know he was dead he did not know the
second type are people that have
unfinished business
and then we go to our evil one
the ones that have never lived but just
randomly show up because they sense
what we're doing equipment is drawing
them okay to continue on this one is a
really really good device basically if
you come up to this
if this thing starts to go off it will
tell us by color what direction they're
coming from
they can also answer our questions
directly through this now here's our
favorite right here um this right here
used to be the old xbox games dude
modified xbox 360. there you go
and what this does
is this device was able to pick up
skeleton
shapes
that were not there so we'll be using
this a lot tonight and we will be able
to pick up skeleton type
visions
anybody have any questions before we go
let's go do this i warn you we're going
to be doing a lot of stairs tonight
nobody mentions stairs
10 000 steps you're going to get them
yeah this is the scariest part
[Music]
so this actually where we're standing
is the cemetery that i mentioned to you
earlier at one point it was a native
american burial ground and then it
became a jewish cemetery and if it's
okay with you guys now it's a car park
now it's a car park i told you there was
some cement i wasn't kidding right
it's not a glamorous place and if my
body
was left here
i don't think i'd be that happy guys
would you i really would want to be
buried in a nice place so what this is
that i've put down it's called the
spirit box and basically what it is it's
an old am fm radio that's been set up to
go through stations very quickly we're
looking for direct answers to our
questions it's kind of like a seance
thing this is the way we can directly
speak to the spirits is there anyone of
jewish descent that was buried here that
would like to speak with us
me i heard it say me i didn't see me
can you repeat your name
i heard walter
i heard walt
you did yeah
walter thank you so much for joining us
tonight can i have a new mirror account
of how many spirits may be with us
are there any spirits here
that know any of the people that are
here with me this evening
yes
do you know ethan
are you a relative of ethan
[Music]
i heard you oh that was a body strike i
don't hear
ask a question okay you possibly have a
relative here do you know who i am
who's mike
mike's my grandpa
oh but he's not here
he passed away recently but in another
state he got here they could travel they
could travel is your name mike sir
substitute with something else
i heard yes i heard yes are you ethan's
grandfather yes or no
it said eat yeah for sure
dude it's going up
grandpa what would you like me to know
something about my dad
is ethan's dad okay no yeah no
what's wrong with ethan's dad
he's healthy as far as i know do you
miss him
that couldn't have been if you did not
hear that i give up that was as clear as
could be yeah if you're his grandfather
will you please turn the rods towards
him
[Music]
okay
you just got a ghost tug remember i was
kidding with you in the hallway i called
those ghost hugs they really are ghost
hugs that's their way of being able to
give us a high
so you just got a hug from your grandpa
that's very nice
that was productive
we talked to your grandfather
i found out i got to sell my ethereum
i've been trying to tell you that you
didn't have to talk to a ghost you don't
like that
[Music]
smells
ghosty that
a lot of echo all right so where are we
uh at this moment so we came inside now
and we're in the main auditorium
and what we're going to do now is
actually do an official ghost
investigation i'd like to see everybody
use the tools sam got something you got
something
i did a second ago okay so that's what
we're looking for those fluctuations so
so what do these do other they just
confirm or that are they just kind of
like
are they gonna take me somewhere
um tahiti sometimes but that's an extra
charge
yeah yeah no they won't take anywhere
okay let's start walking guys let's see
what we can find
let's actually keep your keep your spook
senses tingling everybody put up like
scooby doo or yeah zach goes along zach
goes ahead like the canary
canary in a [ __ ] coal mine so what
i'd like to do is i'd like to take us
upstairs there's a couple rooms that i
think have
[Laughter]
yeah see what you're getting
we'll put you first okay um it's just
flickering now okay
anybody else getting anything
check your instruments people
keep your eye on the prize we're here to
kill ghosts can we anger the ghosts
it's not my style well i just want i
want to provoke them
we'll try in a nice way okay
sorry hippie ghost hunter what can i say
no i like it
we're gonna go up this way
everybody please be careful it's very
dark in here and we're going upstairs oh
[ __ ] it's hella dark in here yeah
so we're climbing up to an area right
now called the tower has a very
interesting history
there is some chances of some possible
suicides that have happened up here too
so let's see what we get
it is quite a climb
i'm going to put this over here
is that the [ __ ] cosby doll what is
that
so what is this
looks like i don't know what that is
okay so we are now up
at the top of this building there are
rumors that people have literally
opened up those windows and thrown
themselves right out they have found
bodies right there at the bottom so i
mean if you want to commit suicide this
tower would be the place to do it
anybody getting anything on any of their
instruments
i'm getting something in like this
vicinity over here
it's like a cursed bill cosby doll maybe
why don't you grab it i ain't touching
that man it's paranormal activity
what is it looks like a curse bill cosby
wait ice
no [ __ ] you put that there hand to god
bro no way
no [ __ ] way oh there's
is that you're the one that spotted it
my hand you put that here because i see
something sitting in the corner and i'm
like what the [ __ ] is it i saw it first
i did zach saw it first you think that
plays out drove with you we couldn't
even see it
did you guys burn it or throw it away
yeah what did you do first of all first
of all somebody clearly put that there
zach hey dude you saw i drove behind you
the whole time this [ __ ] doll haunts
us
is there a chance that this is just here
coincidentally
i mean they made a lot of it no such
thing as a coincidence so is that like a
popular manufacturer doll yeah it's a
cosby doll i made a shitload of ones
with the heat sensors
yeah see see if you get anything on
there
is there some history i should be
knowing about with you in this doll
because you're really freaking out right
now
oh my
god i'm a cosby kid
oh no
this thing is so cursed bro this is the
type of thing that you burn and then it
shows back up in your room
bad voodoo in here man all
[ __ ] you right on here [ __ ] them off
dude
but the chance of it showing up here is
crazy that's why i think zach did it
because he spotted it but is it it's
possible that somebody left you here
i i mean that's weird i don't think i've
ever seen a cosby doll
you've never seen one well i remember
when it looks like kind of i don't even
want to touch it
i don't touch it no i ain't touching it
touch it
it's just a doll don't touch it
wow
oh my gosh
you really jump out of the way come on
wait here let me let me dousing rod it
see if you get anything out of that i
don't even know how to handle religion
religion religion when you threw it yeah
seriously when we threw that you saw
religion yeah it's still at the top all
right well who put the doll here
like that was the cost
because i see the [ __ ] thing how did
you how could you tell it's dark it
doesn't matter why would i
get access to this this [ __ ]
over here at it
[Music]
i drove behind you okay all right
chances
is that maybe someone left it here could
be dude maybe this is his home i mean
this is an old building and they also
you know they used to take charitable
donations here for kids yeah
so
maybe somebody left this behind yeah
should we move it out of here should we
move it down i'm not touching it i ain't
touching it just leave it can we throw
the doll out the window
zach you want to throw it up dude i
didn't bring it in whoever brought it in
got to throw it out thought work all
right let's do a spirit bomb okay
did someone
leave this doll here on purpose
they're leaving a message
is someone trying to send us a message
with this doll
he just got out it man did you leave the
dog i did not leave the dog
does this have something to
do with someone's history here when they
were kids
okay if something if there's something a
presence in the room that touched me
please cross the rocks
you feel better
um
i don't know
the spirit box didn't say oh
okay wait ask it another question
if uh if you are a nice spirit cross the
rods
[Music]
i feel like something
it's like um pushing pushing oh my god
that's good right it's good so we have a
nice spirit were you trying to get
someone else's attention if so would you
please cross the rod oh that was big was
that you or the goal i don't know who
left the cosby doll
if you know what this where the cosby
doll came from cross the rods
holy oh my zach do you see that
was it pointing at me no
really you really honestly feel this
doll is cursed yes for sure all right if
you guys want to throw it out there and
get out the window all right [ __ ] you
cause we don't dude
all right that thing is that thing
look at it there you go that's just
standing up
he's walking away
okay
it's just
so this area right here is a maze
oh [ __ ]
yeah there's going to be yeah there's
good there's going to be um
a lot of um
weird bodies down here yeah is that the
quartering
oh my god
sorry what the [ __ ] is this
what is that did you do that no
okay that's the second one
what the [ __ ]
everyone's happy
i mean we're in a firehouse we are
second creepy doll second creepy dog
[ __ ] hey man
[Music]
that person is oh they're getting up now
they're standing up
i had a temperature change oh you had a
temperature change
the fridge he's doing the spooky
skeleton he really is
can you please like give us a wave or
something
oh he's definitely way better yeah thank
you thank you for waving are you seeing
anything there's another one there's
another one oh [ __ ] spooky skeleton
okay so now we have two skeletons
there it is
dude no this ain't real man
what do you mean
please can i go stand over there
yes go stand over there so let's get you
on there to verify how this works
the temperature no they're happy okay
we're having temperature fluctuations
guys ethan it's right next it is right
next to you he's he looks like he's in
the chat getting heat i'm getting heat
okay so we have verification in two ways
sorry
sorry lena
it tastes the air tastes like
humid
it really kind of like uh chalky
wait what angle little they're saying
little
that's my last name
my last name's klein right it means
little in german it's true really yeah
oh it's like compulsory no it's it's you
know what's happening it's disappearing
should i sit in the chair
why not i mean that's a little rude
can we please get the name of the spirit
that's been with us
edison is this you
did you hurt yourself sir
i did
it's me
are you scared
her box says slain
do you want us to leave this area yes or
no
okay yes
did you hear that yeah the temperature
just went up like three degrees it's
telling us to leave the area
[Music]
we will thank you very much for
appearing to us thank you thank you
thank you and we are going to move on
and respect your wishes
oh there's a smell in here boy yeah
there's a ghost smell yeah
anybody getting anything
any instruments going it says death here
so
i'm assuming that's good
either
yeah
what
um no way that
doll
it's the same though i chuck
maybe someone around here collects cosby
dolls
damn don't touch it yeah i mean
you got the kevorkin you're gonna get
cursed dude
i i again as 15 years of a ghost hunter
i've never seen so much stuff involved
with dolls especially bill cosby dolls
yeah
that's crazy man
okay this is where we want to go
and we're going to turn you back on dude
this is saw dude
for ghost hunting
oh no it says the same i heard
said something didn't you hear it i'm in
the walls ben guys we're getting a 3.5
on this
okay so let's go with that
i'm also going to set up a different
device is there someone in this room
with us right now
russell
is there a russell in this room with us
i think we now know all the alive
achmeds
somebody called you handsome so whoever
they're talking to is handsome oh it's
probably there's nobody here yeah yeah
are you sitting in this bathroom with us
right now
i heard over there i swear to god i saw
something over there okay let's go move
in that direction yeah i i don't know if
it's the light or something but i saw
something just like run super fast
spirits
are you trying to communicate with zach
bernstein yeah
did you hear a whisper zack
i did you wanna hold my hand
[Music]
where'd you see the spirit it was like
over there okay let's go oh for [ __ ]
sake what what
the [ __ ] way
what
why is there an lp there that's the
scariest thing i've ever raised
go go
you guys are [ __ ] man
yo i'm just gonna sing it
[Applause]
[Music]
um
what is that
wait who put that on everyone's here
[Music]
um guys guys you're not gonna like what
i just got on this
it just said jewish people no it did it
i swear to god it just said jewish
people
i thought i saw something what that i
mean
let's move on let's get out you all make
me feel like i'm at shutter island right
now dude someone told me long ago he's
losing his mind
who's here right now and who said jewish
people it's me hitler he's here
he said he's here
hitler no
are you are you a john fogerty fan are
you doing this
no okay someone's [ __ ] with me
we're in the back rooms well i think dog
told me to watch out for rooms like this
what's your favorite crazy ghoulish
video now from what i understand about
the history of this place
it is rumored
that someone drowned in one of these
rooms smells lemony in here they were
doing a water experiment and rumor has
it that someone actually drowned
during one of the water experiments
who are you zach other known as uh
i thought they said this is nate
nate are you still here with us if so
can you please cross the rods
oh [ __ ] those rods are definitely
crossing
are you doing that olivia olivia those
[ __ ] are crossed
i'm not moving explain that
nate what are you trying to tell us
bullshitting now
i thought he said [ __ ] in the crowd
are you bullshitting us
what should i eat for dinner
very hardy they told you something very
hearty nate did you have anything to do
with those cosby dolls
hello
or hell no tyler jello so you're a fan
of bill cosby and fat albert
why nate
i hate to break it to you
have you heard that bill cosby uh went
to jail
he did
you still
you still a fan after all that nate
i think it was a question he did
oh he did he did yeah he did yeah
like over 50 women
this is the first time it's gone off all
night okay
nate is that you that's triggering our
device
please make it go higher oh wait wait
wait oh look at that hi nate welcome
how can we help you
he farted
excuse you
can you please trigger our devices thank
you oh right on command thank you so
much for responding to our questions
i want to ask you guys one more thing
before we wrap i wanted to do a bit of
an experiment probably with the person
that's the most scared you know how we
use that spirit box earlier
would you be willing to put on some
headphones
and sit in that room
and we'll ask questions out here and see
if you could just answer the questions
do you want to do it
anything for the show
500 bucks
come on
500 easy money
dude nate was sick nate was a [ __ ]
people dude there was a homie he was
like oh that cosby no he was upset about
bill cosby he really was
he made all our devices go off i mean
he's been the best one we've had i'll do
it if a b goes in there with me okay
come on av let's go
250 a piece there you go
yeah
all right all right okay good job thank
you guys this thing's going off this
thing's going crazy right now there's
somebody by itself
did it really yeah
literally just opened you saw that right
well this thing's been going crazy too
call older stare it says we're just
looking for
something like guesses or no's or
something that makes sense do you know
what i mean are you okay with that yeah
we're gonna ask as soon as i get back in
here we're just gonna ask questions okay
but you can't hear what we're asking
otherwise it would mess up the
experiment don't close the [ __ ] door
though we're not gonna close the door
we're not gonna close the door nate is
that you that's speaking to us
nipple
this guy's getting paid for this all
right you look like a psychopath okay
fourth
four have we spoken hey
tell me
are you related to zach in any way yes
yes
spirit
were you there when zach ate that girl's
sweaty ass out when they were hiking
spirit can you please say zach's name to
him
i just heard my name i'm out man no way
yes
yes
yes what did i ask what did i ask i got
five on this too no [ __ ] way right
now so we were asking to tell zach his
name
[ __ ] i swear to god we have it on
camera
i gotta see the tape it's on camera it's
on camera i swear to [ __ ] dude you're
gonna you're gonna freak when you see
that footage wow
okay crazy [ __ ] wait dude
what is that it looks all burnt it looks
burnt
yeah it's just a duplicate banjo
it's my great great grandpappy
wait is it really
yeah what's his name zariah berchevus
yeah
and that's actually a photo he was a
good old picker dude look at him let's
get out of here i'm freaked out
okay we are back from our ghost hunts
how was that for you uh in terms of a
paranormal adventure
i think was fantastic almost every piece
of equipment went off at some point
which is incredible that's what you want
i mean that does not happen every time
how do you feel i mean it's your first
ghost hunt how do you think it went well
we had a few great moments we had me
communicating with my
grandpa uh-huh
housing rods yeah i say that right
mm-hmm yeah
you're not gonna like this
but i was faking it with the rods were
you yeah okay that's okay
sorry it's okay
what the [ __ ] you did what a way to be a
buzzkill what is this
really that bad yeah well why did you
even say that
why would you do that
i just were debriefing i'm just being
honest okay but you weren't faking when
your grandfather is his name really mike
or his name is mike okay and that really
did come through
yes so okay
so it was just stuff that you did that
you were faking the rods i i manipulated
them okay to move in
can i ask you a question sure when you
were actually when we were shooting you
and you said you kind of tasted like a
chalky taste was that real or no i was
lying okay
i'm sorry yeah
just just figuring this out okay
everyone else was wait we're gonna cut
we're gonna cut all this out
really that bad
what
i mean you've got to let people believe
okay let's reach over ask it again
come on
this is the first time
all right we gotta let people believe re
ask the question
so
when you said you felt like a
smelt or tasted kind of a chalky
sensation when you were near that spirit
was that was that true
no
when you were next to the spirit when we
were shooting you said you felt like a
chalky flavor or smell or something was
that was that legitimate yeah for sure
it felt like
the humidity went crazy and i was like
sweating and i had like a chalky taste
in my mouth so i definitely felt some
kind of shift
okay yeah
okay good it's good to hear and the
dowsing rods seem to be moving
yeah i mean i wasn't a believer going
into this
but
it's
i don't know i mean i just felt the rods
moving in my hands
and i really don't know how to explain
it that's interesting it's good yeah did
you guys all feel that when you had the
ones that used the dowsing rods did you
actually physically kind of feel
somebody pushing them a little bit yeah
i felt his rod
so let's show do a show of hands who was
legitimately spooked at one time this
evening
dan
[ __ ]
we had a professional with us she didn't
seem scared if she started freaking out
then i'd be scared so raise your hands
if you're afraid of bringing home bad
demons
three go on go on zach said no and then
he raised his hand so let's do the life
ceremony to make sure that we all leave
here okay pure if you guys don't mind if
we can stand and
hold hands oh great
okay
okay
i surround us all with the white light
you are protected
any spirits we encounter tonight
we thank you for making your presence
known but you are not welcome to follow
us home again i repeat but you cannot
follow us home
i surround us all with peace
amen
peace and love amen amen
just when i thought i was out they
pulled me back in we gotta go get the
cosby doll
i feel like we won the squid games and
we're going back in i still i feel like
we've been here for hours and i still
don't know
where we are
after you my friend
there's the guy on the floor oh thank
you for that
okay did you hear that
that scared the [ __ ] out of me i
definitely heard that
don't like that
okay there's the doll what if the doll
was gone
i hear stuff down there
hi could i get some light thank you this
is so much scarier with like two people
you touched the [ __ ] you need to get
white lighted again
what was the ghost name walter
don't don't don't say it i shouldn't
have said his name
is that warding off spirits or is that
luring them
i feel like we're locked in we're about
to see pyramid head come down that
hallway i don't know i heard something
for real now
we gotta okay okay uh shoot lena sorry i
understand i understand
okay
lock the door i'm out of here man
let's go ask me the doll
i'll get them out of here
lena your hair your hair
did you rattle something no i didn't you
must have tripped over something
it's way worse without linda
it is so much scarier with a small group
how was it without linda that should
scare me
[Music]
what
[Music]
you